new information emerges in the jacob
blake shooting the rnc begins with a
bang as republicans hit on crime coveted
and communism
and nikki haley and tim scott compete
for speech of the night i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn protect your online privacy
today at expressvpn.com
ben well we'll get to the opener of the
republican national convention which was
really well produced i mean much better
produced
than the dnc which had all sorts of sort
of technological hiccups the rnc
actually ran very smoothly
which you would expect from president
trump i mean the fact is that there's
one thing president trump knows and that
thing is reality tv and so
the convention was actually quite well
produced we'll get to everything
convention related in just one second
first
i need to give you an update on the
jacob blake case so i suggested
yesterday that perhaps we should wait
for more information
you know because we needed more
information and all we had was a
grainy piece of footage that was taken
from across the street
the first seconds of which were
completely cut off and which showed
jacob blake
a 29 year old black man walking away
from police whose guns were drawn on him
and then he reaches into a car and then
they shoot him
and this prompted the likes of joe biden
to issue awful statements
on this whole thing jumping to the
conclusion that this was once again
systemic
american racism against black americans
and unjustified shooting of an
unarmed black man caught on camera that
nothing had preceded it
everything just happened the way that
benjamin crump the attorney said
remember benjamin crump's claim was that
jacob blake
was a good samaritan who basically had
gone to break up a fight between two
women and then had walked away
and the cops for no reason just decided
to follow him and shoot him well
it turns out that shock of shocks that
was not in fact the case first of all it
turns out as we knew yesterday that
jacob blake
there's an open warrant out on jacob
blake
for things including sexual assault and
domestic violence
and joe none of this stopped joe biden
from putting out the statement yesterday
joe biden put out the following
statement about the jacob blake shooting
in the absence
of any surrounding evidence right
without waiting for any new evidence to
come out
he said yesterday in kenosha wisconsin
jacob lake was shot seven times in the
back as police attempted to restrain him
from getting into his car
his children watched from inside the car
and bystanders watched in disbelief
no mention of the fact that this was a
man for whom there was an arrest
warranty out with three kids in the back
of his car now typically
if you have a guy out an arrest warrant
out on a guy for domestic violence and
sexual assault of a minor which is
what this was it was sexual assault of a
15 year old i believe was was the actual
case that they're talking about
according to statutory law
somebody underage the typically you
don't let that person get in the car
with kids and drive away but in any case
joe biden wrote his children watched
from inside the car and bystanders
watched in disbelief and this morning
the nation wakes up yet again with grief
and outrage that yet another black
american is a victim of excessive force
so he's just going to go right with the
excessive force line
this calls for immediate full and
transparent investigation and the
officers must be held accountable so he
already knows the outcome of the
investigation which is magic
and i definitely trust democrats on
preliminarily jumping to conclusions
considering
that kamala harris and elizabeth warren
and many members of the democratic party
are still claiming
years later after two independent
prosecutorial investigations state
prosecutors
in ferguson missouri and one obama doj
investigation
that the shooting of michael brown was
not in fact a murder it was a justified
shooting by a police officer they are
still claiming it's a murder so i
definitely trust these people when it
comes to their assessment
of criminality joe biden said these
shots pierce the soul of our nation
jill and i pray for jacob's recovery and
for his children equal justice has not
been real for black americans and so
many others we are at an inflection
point we must dismantle systemic racism
so this was an element of systemic
racism apparently
he still didn't know whether the
shooting was unjustified he still had no
evidence even if it was unjustified that
it actually had anything to do
with racism it is the urgent task before
us we must fight to honor the ideals
laid in the original american promise
which we are yet to attain
that all men and women are created equal
but more importantly that they must be
treated equally
well let me just point out that if a
person resists arrest
by which we mean that the person resists
arrest to the point where
apparently there are reports that he was
tased and he walked away from it and he
was
throwing off officers and then reaches
into their car i have a feeling the cops
don't let white people get away with
that
either just as a general rule okay in
any case new tape emerges from a
different angle
the the cell phone video is not
particularly good but you can get like a
brief view here of what's going on so
this is the other side of the suv where
jacob blake was shot shortly before you
see him
walking around the other side of the car
and being shot
if you pause it right there you can see
that jacob blake
is basically on the ground right and
then he shakes the officers loose as
you're about to see
and he gets up and he starts walking
away from the officers who now have
their weapons drawn because he's
resisting arrest
and so this is what the tape shows right
he literally
throws off the officers he's struggling
he's resisting arrest
people are standing around shouting at
the police officers he gets up
and he starts walking around the car now
if you're a police officer and he's just
shrugged you off right he's just fought
you off
and he reaches into the car are we under
the impression that he is reaching into
the car and he reaches down into the car
that he's reaching down into the car
for like what exactly
his id i mean what exactly is he
reaching for at that point if you're a
cop
you are trained in that situation that
if somebody reaches into the car
after having resisted arrest if there's
a good shot that that person
might be going for something that is not
going to be good for you hey so in any
case does this mean that the
shooting was justified no we don't have
enough evidence still we still don't
know
but is this the original story we were
told by benjamin crump that this is a
man who's just breaking up a fight
between a good samaritan breaking up a
fight between two women
and then just calmly walking back to his
car when he was accosted for no reason
by the police
is that what you see on that tape so
bottom line is this
maybe everybody should wait for more
evidence to come out i know
controversial
maybe everybody should wait for more
evidence to come out but no we jump to
the conclusion that this is systemic
american
racism always and forever this is the
line
systemic american racism is always what
is to blame for every situation
that you don't like whether or not there
is evidence
the officers involved in the shooting
are already placed on administrative
leave they are said to be cooperating
with investigators according to the
wisconsin
department of justice and the state doj
has already launched an investigation
into the shooting meanwhile the police
union representing the officers on the
kenosha police force released a
statement on monday criticizing
wisconsin governor tony evers
who immediately condemned the excessive
force used by cops pete dates the
president of the kenosha
professional police association said
anytime deadly force is used our hearts
go out to those
affected by it we assure you an
independent investigation is being
conducted by the wisconsin doj
division of criminal investigation
but none of that matters because the
riots started
and the riots people really don't like
furniture and they really don't like
cars
the the police association said until
the investigation is complete
we ask that you withhold pre-judgment
about the incident and please let the
process take place
governor evers statement on the incident
wholly irresponsible and not reflective
of the hard-working members of the law
enforcement community
not to mention the citizens of the city
of kenosha as always the video currently
circulating does not capture all the
intricacies
of a highly dynamic incident we ask that
you withhold from passion judgment until
all the facts are known and released
this seems reasonable
we along with citizens of the great city
of kenosha ask for peace to let the
process
play out fairly and impartially but nope
we're not going to do any of
those things until last night kenosha
burned because this is how it works
politicians decide they can make hay off
of claiming that america is systemically
racist
in no way does this make america a
better place in no way does this improve
race relations in the united states
when you claim that every individual
incident
is an indicator a symptom of a broader
systemic problem
and without evidence then what you are
doing is setting the scene
for burning of cities when you suggest
that individual incidents without
evidence must actually be racist
then what you are doing is something
truly terrible and you bear
responsibility for what comes next
and that is what's happening right here
that is what's happening
you can see on this video in kenosha
people these are i assume
white uh you can see in the video it's
like white antifa members probably
setting fire to that dumpster that
dumpster right there that was a
systemically racist dumpster
there's a dump truck right here that is
a systemically racist dump truck i'm so
glad they burned that dump truck now
that bastard can't be systemically
racist anymore
they also burned down a furniture store
so that was important because those
couches were systemically racist
there were couches inside and those
couches some of them were white and some
of them were brown and we have no idea
the proportionality the couches were
systemically racist
they also burned a bunch of cars which
was good because the cars were
systemically racist
all of these objects were systemically
racist and it seems to me that the black
lives matter movement
which has resulted in this sort of chaos
in major american cities across the
country
i'm wondering what's the good it did i'm
waiting i'm waiting seriously what is
the good that it did
in fact american perceptions of black
lives matter are back where they were
before the george floyd shooting which
demonstrates exactly
how much goodwill the blm movement has
completely blown in the united states
as well they should have because this
behavior is indicative
of a serious issue okay when it turns
out that protests routinely devolve into
rioting and looting
perhaps there is a problem we're gonna
get to more of this in a second by the
way
the new york times headline i should
just say the new york times tweeted out
this was their tweet about kenosha
being burned last night quote peaceful
marches in kenosha wisconsin against the
police shooting of a black man gave way
to fires and destruction oh they just
gave way did they
fascinating so if the anti-lockdown
protests had devolved into burning down
capital buildings would they have just
given way
or would it have been that the
protesters turned out to be rioters and
looters is that what it'd have turned
out to be
the new york times headline by the way
on all this was fires in kenosha reflect
anger after police shooting of jacob
well the fires reflected the anger
not the people were angry and so they
randomly burned down businesses
and burned down a church with a giant
sign that said black lives matter in
front
the fires themselves reflected anger
incredible incredible
see this in the leftist way of thinking
unfortunately
in the far left way of thinking the
angrier you are at the system the more
the system is to blame for your anger
therefore your anger is always justified
and any resistance to the system
is justified as well in fact if you
really want to show how bad the system
is you burn crap because that
demonstrates how
you wouldn't be this angry if this
system weren't corrupt right you
wouldn't be this angry for no good
reason
barack obama said this directly about
the ferguson missouri riots when those
were happening
after the officer darren wilson was
acquitted
after that after the grand jury didn't
indict barack obama went out there said
people
don't just make the stuff up except that
in that particular case everything was
actually made up but the idea is the
more angry you are
the more you must be justified in your
anger which of course is an outright lie
it's an outright lie we don't know what
happened in the jacob lake case and we
do know what happened in this chicago
case where everybody decided to ransack
the loop
they ransacked the loop after hearing
that a 15 year old boy was shot for no
reason by the cops it turned out to be a
20 year old man who's shooting at the
cops so it turns out people make up crap
all the time white black and green
people make up crap all the time that
helps their case
it doesn't justify this sort of behavior
and it undermines whatever you're
attempting to do for sure
okay now in a second we're going to get
to how this plays in peoria because this
does have a significant impact on the
election we'll get to that in one moment
first
let us talk about the fact that hiring
these days can be particularly difficult
there are a lot of people who are
looking for jobs there are a lot of
employers who are looking to hire up
how do you match the employer with the
employee well this is where zip
recruiter comes in zip recruiter will
send your job
to over 100 of the web's leading job
sites they don't stop there with their
powerful matching technology
zip recruiters scans thousands of
resumes to find people with the right
experience and then actively invites
them to apply to your job
zip recruiter makes the entire hiring
process efficient and effective with
features like screening questions to
filter candidates and an all-in-one
dashboard where you can review and rate
your candidates
zip recruiter is so effective that four
out of five employers who post unzip
recruiter get a quality candidate within
the very first day
right now to try ziprecruiter for free
my listeners can go to ziprecruiter.com
dailywire that is ziprecruiter.com
d-a-i-l-y-w-i-r-e zip recruiter dot com
slash daily wire let's say for example
that you had somebody who worked at your
office
like a town crier let's let's call him
povel for example and let's say that
each morning
he just started announcing out of the
blue they had 10 seconds to airtime when
the teleprompter wasn't even up yet
you might think to yourself well pavel
love you man but ziprecruiter it is for
you if you need to replace someone like
powell you need to check out
ziprecruiter.com
dailywire that is ziprecruiter the
smartest way to hire
okay so the headline from the new york
times again is that jacob blake shooting
prompts tense protests and fires in
several cities oh did it prom fires
did it prompt the fires weird because it
seems that fires don't break out on
their own
it seems like it prompted a bunch of
violent maniacs to go out and do violent
maniacal things
who would have but you can't you can
never devolve
agency on people who do bad things the
system is always to blame for bad things
happening this is the common thread
in so much leftward thinking and it is
wrong nearly all the time
individual behavior as it turns out in a
free country is generally attributable
to the individual it is not attributable
to the system
we have moved from in a view of racism
in the united states that racism
is a barrier to people making free
decisions two people making free and bad
decisions is a result of racism
that is a wide difference it used to be
that
americans were angry at racism because
actual instances of racism deprived
people of the ability to make decisions
that were good for themselves
now people make active bad decisions for
themselves and their neighbors
and we blame racism for the active bad
decisions they're making they have no
agency whatsoever
that's the way all these headlines are
phrased from the new york times julia
julie bosman reporter from new york
times writes like this
peaceful marches in protest of a police
shooting gave way to fires destruction
and looting in kenosha
as a strip of businesses in a central
residential neighborhood was consumed in
flames early tuesday
residents emerged from their houses
overnight to gape at billowing smoke
that could be seen for miles
lost in the blaze neighbor said was a
mattress store well those mattresses
were systemically racist i mean let's be
honest about that
those are some really really
systemically racist mattresses
a storefront church i mean that i can't
think of anything more systemically
racist than a storefront church a
mexican restaurant i mean my god
the cultural appropriation i mean even
if it's owned by mexican americans
that's cultural appropriation a cell
phone store cell phone systemically
racist as we know
less than a mile away a probation and
parole office was also
on fire the national guard was called in
blm
has been burning cities blm has been
destroying cities
something like over 30 people have died
in the current blm riots
some 30 people have died in the blm
riots
okay and people are getting shot people
are getting killed
okay it is it it's obviously the police
right it's obviously that the cops are
the ones who are who are most at fault
here when we watch cities burn okay so
all of this has
a relatively large political impact okay
so
that was the basis for the rnc last
night the democrats completely ignored
this for like a full-on week
for a full-on week the democrats
completely ignored everything that was
going on
in these major cities and it turns out
americans care about it there are polls
that demonstrate that americans care
about there's a pew poll that came out
last week
59 percent of americans say they are
deeply worried about increased violence
in america's major cities
which they should be 63 by the way say
they are concerned about coronavirus
so that means that this is a top
priority and democrats completely
ignored it
so it's not surprising that republicans
decided that they were going to push on
this particular
issue as well they should that's
particularly true given that president
trump's strategy here
is apparently to win over some of the
people in the middle but it is also
to drive out rural votes in the same way
that he did in 2016.
that strategy could bear fruit given the
media's unwillingness to cover this
stuff honestly
given the democrats unwillingness to
call out evil and violence for exactly
what it is
okay we'll get to more of this in just
one second we'll get started with the
rnc in just one second first
you've heard me talk about how important
it is to have a vpn now that a lot of
you are working from home it's even more
important to choose a vpn that you trust
i can say with full confidence
expressvpn is the best vpn on the market
and here's why number one
expressvpn doesn't log your data lots of
really cheap or free vpns that make
money by selling your data to ad
companies
expressvpn has developed a technology
called trusted server that makes it
impossible for their servers to log any
of your information
number two speed i've heard a lot of
vpns in the past many slow your
connection down or make your device
sluggish
i've been using express vpn for
literally years at this point my
internet speeds are always
blazing fast and my internet activity is
always protected also expressvpn really
easy to use you can install it basically
with a click of a button
with one more click it's now running on
your computer and you're protected
it's not just me saying this wired cnet
diverge many other tech journals rate
expressvpn the number one
vpn in the world so protect yourself for
the vpn i use and trust use my link at
expressvpn.com today get an extra three
months for free
on a one year package that's
expressvpn.com visit
expressvpn.com ben to learn more again
that's expr essvpn.com
slash ben and you get an extra three
months free on a one-year package
meanwhile the rnc began last night
and it began on an upbeat note there
were a couple of themes that were
pressed last night
one was america is a great place which
is something that the democrats did not
say the entirety of the convention it
was america
is a horrible hellscape and you can tell
by the way the media are covering it how
dishonest the media are so the media
proclaimed
that basically trump down
the rnc and the trump campaign
downplayed america last night it was a
dark vision of america
no that was the dnc where they were
claiming that america was systemically
racist
that everybody in america was going to
die from covet that we were living on
the verge of a dictatorship that was
that was the campaign
night after night last week barack obama
said we are literally living on the
verge of dictatorship
michelle obama said there's a
never-ending list of black americans
being murdered by the cops
so if you're going to talk about
dystopian hellscape views of the united
states
it's pretty obvious that the democrats
were pushing that line but since the
gaslighting by the media has gone so
incredibly far
we've now reversed the narrative and the
narrative is that when republicans talk
about how america
is a great place yes there are problems
here but america is an incredible place
founded on good principles and that we
are getting past covet
and that we are working to solve
problems and that we can do this if
granted freedom
the media played this as though we were
as though as the republicans
have a dark vision of america no
americans have a dark vision of marxism
republicans have a dark vision
of the future that democrats would like
to see pervade and frankly looking at
america's major blue cities
i have no no reason to to doubt that
particular narrative
my favorite headline by the way of the
day had nothing to do with the rnc my
favorite headline of the day
was the la times being very very angry
that republicans keep beating up
on california it's it's it was pretty
incredible here was the la times
headline last night speakers at the rnc
turn california into a dystopian
punchline portraying america's most
populous state as a dangerous wasteland
ruled by liberal politicians who are
oblivious to public safety
now actually it turns out that democrats
turned california into a dystopian
punchline
um i live here they have turned this
place into a hellscape
i was talking to producer nick and let
me tell you something producer nick is
the kind of guy
who likes to hunt bears in the woods
with like just a knife he brings a torch
and a knife to the woods to hunt bears
he went down to santa monica he's like
i'm not gonna
survive here i'm leaving in like the
next 37 seconds
producer nick is the kind of guy who
dates women who train wolves and
producer nick went down to santa monica
and he's like um
this is this is quite awful i think we
need to leave
hey california has turned into hellscape
because of democrats because of
democrats but the media are like
how dare republicans portray major
american cities that are on fire
overrun with homelessness and poverty
how dave
how dare they portray these places as
bad okay so the actual narrative last
night is that america is quite wonderful
and it is filled with wonderful people
and democrats keep telling you that your
neighbors are racist and terrible people
while simultaneously saying the
government will solve all of your
problems in solving none of them
the rnc opened on an optimistic notes
there was a video narrated by john
voight it was quite good there's a lot
of focus at the rnc
on the quote unquote common man a lot
more than there was at the democratic
party national convention the dnc
was based almost entirely on the idea
that donald trump is a bad orange man
who's bad in orange as we discussed last
week
there was very little focus on the
middle class or low-income americans and
what
democrats are going to do to uplift them
there is almost no focus on policy
there's certainly no focus on the riots
in the looting
instead it was america's systemically
racist and joe biden the octogenarian
political animal who's been there for 50
years is going to be your your beacon of
light in the wilderness
republicans went in a different
direction they made an overt play for
people who were middle
and and lower income and they made an
overplay for people who are fearful of
what's going on in america's major
cities
here was the opening video narrated by
my friend john voight
we are america despite unpredictable
events
we as americans work together to
overcome challenges
write our own stories the legends for
our posterity
america land of promise
land of opportunity land of heroes
land of greatness and that's good stuff
there's nothing wrong with the sort of
patriotism
i know that at the dnc people were
trying to elide under god from the early
hours of the dnc before he saw them in
prime time and then lie about it by
having joe biden do the
have his grandkids do the pledge of
allegiance and sing the national anthem
but there's no question which party has
a greater sense
of patriotism i mean that's pretty
obvious at this point is it not
i mean the entire democratic party
platform is that america's systemically
racist and terrible
and then joe biden tries to buy it back
a little bit so he can pretend to be
moderate
okay then the rnc did something that i
thought that they absolutely needed to
do i've been preaching it for weeks on
this program i said it would be
political malpractice if they did not do
it
they played a video of various
democratic governors
saying that donald trump gave them what
they needed when it came to covid
which i've been urging the trump
administration to do for quite a while
and people were shocked by the
brilliance of it don't be shocked i told
you they were going to do this for weeks
or at least that they should
here is a little bit of that video
andrew cuomo and company praising
trump's response to covet
he said everything that i could have
hoped for promise made
promise kept he is ready willing and
able to help
he has been responsive he's done a lot
of good things
what the federal government did was a
phenomenal accomplishment
in our hour of need you all literally
are helping us in a big way
we were at the edge and this is life or
death stuff and we were forever thankful
for that
okay that is true i mean that all of
these democratic governors were praising
president trump on covet
and now of course president trump is the
worst in the world trump also
did a a moment with the first responders
he appeared in a couple of different
videos throughout the night where he was
dealing with
you know quote unquote the common man uh
and uh here he was speaking with first
responders and thanking them it's a good
look for the president
these are the incredible workers that
helped us so much with the
covid we can call it many different
things from
china virus i don't want to go through
all the names because some people may
get insulted but that's the way it is
these are great great people doctors
nurses
firemen policemen we want to thank you
all you have been
incredible and we want to thank you and
all of the millions of people that you
represent
thank you all very much great job yes i
know you're allowed to thank the cops
you're allowed to thank the firemen oh
that's fine
it turns out all that's good all that's
good turns out that
police officers particularly were
particularly focused at the rnc last
night
they should be because when they leave
you know what's been happening in the
cities have you been watching
okay in just a second when you get to
that theme which was pushed very heavily
last night the the trump campaign really
made a heavy pitch last night
for particularly black voters so there
are good polls like a lot of them
showing that trump is actually
outperforming
where he was last time with the black
vote that it is not as monolithic
as the democrats have assumed if trump
makes significant inroads into the black
vote
the democrats have a real problem on
their hands this election's a lot closer
than some of these polls
are suggesting chris wallace pointed
that out last night he's correct we'll
get some more of this
in just one second first many of us have
become expert
homebodies these last few months but
there is a downside to not leaving your
home which is that
often we exercise less and that's why i
love echelon
echelon has a huge lineup of connected
fitness bikes fitness mirrors rowing
machines that give you a fun
challenging workout from the comfort and
safety of your home in as little as 20
minutes
you can get into the best shape of your
life and be active with the entire
family the world-class instructors will
motivate you with daily live and
on-demand classes that are always
available when you need them
and unlike their competitors echelon is
affordable for everyone
their ex1 connected fitness bike is less
than half the price of a peloton so i
actually looked at getting a peloton
for the wife and then we could have cut
a peloton commercial
and then it turns out that it was so
damned expensive i was like well i don't
think we're gonna do that and so we
ended up with an echelon and it is
absolutely
fantastic my wife loves it with echelon
financing you can try them out risk free
for 30 days zero down as little as 46
dollars per month
don't pay a ton for a peloton instead go
check out echelon i mean you're talking
about a quality bike with
classes the whole thing go to
echelonfit.com that's e-c-h-e-l-o-n
fit dot com slash ben echelon fit dot
com
slash ben go check them out right now it
really is a fantastic fantastic product
okay so
the there are a couple themes that the
republicans hit on last night as i
mentioned
they really made a play for black voters
last night and i know that the
the democrats think the way you appeal
to black voters is by suggesting that
they're that america's systemically
racist and the police are evil it turns
out
that 81 percent of black americans want
the same number of police or more in
their communities
that the vast majority of black
americans are not in fact living
below the poverty line that black
americans are by and large middle class
that black americans actually want
safety and security in their communities
that the lie that has been promulgated
by the media and in pop culture
that all black americans are desperate
to get the police out of their
communities
and that they are warm toward
criminality is a lie that has been alive
for decades
and yet that lie is promulgated by the
media specifically in order to quote
unquote blame america for criminality
problems
that exist among individual black
americans which is ridiculous
okay so several republicans hit on the
crime points and then there were several
kind of big name and and very impactful
black speakers at the rnc last night of
course it was closed out by senator tim
scott from south carolina
so jim jordan hit on the point that
democrats
basically are allowing evil to happen in
our major cities while preventing you
from going to work in school
this is true there's no way around this
it is absolutely true
in la they're trying to shut down
private schools while they
permanently allow major protests while
they've allowed looting to ransack half
the city i mean it really is incredible
here is jim jordan the republican
congressman from ohio making this point
democrats refused to denounce the mob
and their response to the chaos
defund the police defund border patrol
and defund our military
and while they're doing all this they're
also trying to take away your guns
look at the positions they've taken the
past few months democrats won't let you
go to church
but they'll let you protest democrats
won't let you go to work
but they'll let you riot and democrats
won't let you go to school
but they'll let you go loot yep yep
and and for security moms you know
people who are living in the suburbs
and that makes a difference because this
is starting to invade the suburbs i mean
you're seeing
blm rioters protesters
in some cases the same groups who are
going into suburbs and screaming at
people to keep them awake at night
this is not relegated to city centers
anymore right people wonder why there is
there seems to be more ire by more
americans at blm these days well that is
why
that is why because this supposedly
started off as a righteous crusade and
it quickly
overthrew those boundaries and turned
into a crusade to destroy
virtually all american founding
principles there's a reason that nicole
hannah jones the de facto editor of the
new york times
says that uh she's proud that these are
the 16 19 riots
okay so this was one message right one
of the messages here
is that the the democrats keep defending
criminality mark and patricia mccloskey
that's the famous couple from st louis
whose gated community was broken into by
black lives matter rioters and it turns
into criminality when you break into a
gated community
and then they held guns outside their
house and were then prosecuted by a st
louis prosecutor who was seeking to
maintain electoral
advantage they spoke at the at the rnc
last night made the point that the
democrats are defending criminals
they're not defending citizens
it seems as if the democrats no longer
view the government's job
as protecting honest citizens from
criminals
but rather protecting criminals from
honest citizens
not a single person in the out of
control mob
you saw our house was charged with a
crime
but you know who was we were
they've actually charged us with
felonies for daring
to defend our home okay and that is
right and i think more and more
americans are picking up on this
and the media have basically blacked out
all coverage
of the of the violence or they've
treated it as the predictable side
effect of systemic american racism
most americans are not up for this they
absolutely are not and meanwhile the rnc
made a pitch for black voters so
herschel walker who's been a longtime
friend of president trump
he played for the new york generals when
when trump was an owner in the usfl
so herschel walker spoke at length about
his friendship with president trump
and it was a good speech he gave a good
speech last night here he was
i've known donald trump for 37 years and
i don't mean just casual ranting to him
from time to time
i'm talking about a deep personal
friendship he taught me that the family
should be your top priority
i watched him treat janitors security
guards and waiters
the same way he retreated vip he made
them feel special
because he knew they were he understands
that they are the people who make this
country run
they clean they cook they build they
drive
they deliver hey all of this is good
right and walker also said listen you
can love both social justice and the
american flag you don't have to be on
the side of flag burners
in order to believe that sometimes
change is necessary here's herschel
walker
just because someone loves and respects
the flag our national anthem and our
country
doesn't mean they don't care about
social justice i care about all those
things
so does donald trump he shows how much
he cares about social justice in the
black community
through his actions and his actions
speaks louder than stickers or slogans
on a jersey
by the way this led because twitter is a
garbage place filled with garbage people
this led
the term uncle tom to trend on twitter
last night and this morning
well well done everybody so black man
thinks differently than you think he
ought to think
lefties and he becomes an uncle tom he's
a sellout to black people everywhere
well apparently among other sellouts was
vernon jones so vernon jones is a state
georgia legislator
and he supports president trump he says
you know when i endorse trump all hell
broke loose because i'm expected to
think a certain way
now you know when i made the public
announcement of my support for president
trump
all hell broke loose i was threatened
called an embarrassment and asked to
resign by my own party
unfortunately that's consistent
with the democratic party and how they
view
independent thinking black men and women
okay and this is absolutely true
obviously is the the democratic party
views the black community as a an
exclusive preserve
for their policies and they should not
because it turns out there are a lot of
black americans who are not really fond
of watching their cities burn while
excuses are made
for the burning by democrats and by the
media we'll get some more of this in
just a second
and the big name guests of the
convention some were good
some were not so good we'll get to all
of that the breakdown coming up first
if you need legal help for your
challenges legalzoom has proven to be a
reliable resource for families and
business owners everywhere during these
unprecedented
times legalzoom has been dedicated to
helping you with the right solutions for
more than 19 years
whether you need a will or a living
trust to protect your family or if you
need help starting a business the right
way with a dba llc nonprofit or more
legalzoom can help you do it it's easy
to get started online
and if you need guidance their network
of attorneys can provide legal advice to
ensure you're making the right choices
since legal zoom is not a law firm you
won't have to leave your home you won't
get charged by the hour there's really
no reason
at all for it to be charged too much for
your lawyering when you can do all of
this quickly and easily using legal zoom
i've been using legalzoom for years
myself long before they were a sponsor
on the show you can use it for wills you
can use it for trust and now they have
an entire legal team that will help you
online as well
visit legalzoomat.com today to take care
of some important things
you need to get done that's
legalzoom.com go check them out right
now
legalzoom.com again when you check out
legalzoom
you're going to get all sorts of great
services and it's easy to get started
and they have a network of attorneys
it's not just a bunch of forums they
have a network of attorneys that can
provide you legal advice so
save money right now over at
legalzoom.com go check them out
right now okay we'll get to more of the
rnc in just a moment
there were a couple big name speakers
who did great last night there was one
who didn't do so great last night
but if you haven't heard by now joe
biden is officially the democratic
party's presidential nominee for 2020 we
know this because we made matt walsh
watch his acceptance speech as part of
our daily wire all access live dnc watch
party it was pretty traumatizing
for him i hope he will survive this week
we have an even better lineup of all
access live to watch the rnc with you
over at dailywire.com starting tonight
10 p.m eastern 7 p.m pacific our own
andrew clavin will be live streaming
president trump's speech and watching
with you taking your comments and
questions letting you know what he
thinks as well we'll be hosting more
live watch parties every day for the
rest of the week so don't miss out all
access members get to join these all
access live sessions where one of us
hops on every night to chat with you
both in live stream and also in the
comments
all access membership also features not
just one but two
leftist tears tumblers with your
membership as well as early and
sometimes exclusive access to new daily
wire products so
head on over to dailywire.com shapiro
right now to get 20 percent
off all access with coupon code access
that's dailywire.com
apparel with coupon code access to get
20 off your membership today you're
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
alrighty so other speakers were great
last night
as i say there are a bunch of black
republicans who
spoke i thought quite wonderfully and
eloquently about the fact that democrats
have simply assumed that the black vote
is there for them kimberly clasek
who is a candidate in baltimore for
congress in elijah cummings whole
district
she cut a great ad the other day about
the destruction the democratic rule has
wrought in baltimore
well she spoke at the rnc and she was
terrific
sadly the same cycle of decay exists and
many of america's democrat-run cities
and yet the democrats still assume that
black people will vote for them no
matter how much they let us down and
take us for granted
we're sick of it we're not going to take
it anymore
the days of blindly supporting the
democrats are coming to an end
in baltimore we have the highest number
of black republicans in the entire
country running for office this election
cycle
joe biden believes we can't think for
ourselves that the color of someone's
skin
dictates their political views we're not
buying the lies anymore
you and your party have neglected us for
far too long okay this is all
excellent excellent stuff okay other
speakers who were great last night uh
there is a
cuban expatriate named maximo alvarez uh
who i believe will be a guest on our
radio show a little bit later today
he was terrific he contrasted the united
states with communist countries
and talked at length about why it is
that america is a fantastic fantastic
place this is a good reminder
gang that people who have actually lived
under tyranny understand just how
wonderful america is and what it would
mean to lose it here's maximo alvarez
who i thought was the most moving
speaker of the night
i have seen people like this before i've
seen movements like this before
i've seen ideas like this before
and i am here to tell you we cannot let
them
take over our country i heard the
promises of fidel castro
and i can never forget all those who
grew up around me
who looked like me who suffered
and starved and died because they
believed those empty promises
they swallowed the communist poison pill
okay and then he talked about the
difference between communism and
americanism he says america is the
greatest country on earth and by the way
this is somebody who should know there
he is maxima alvarez
i may be a cuban born but i am 100
american
this is the greatest country in the
world
and i said this before if i gave away
everything that i have today
it would not equal 1 of what i was given
when i came to this great country of
ours
the gift of freedom and the fact that
this is a man who understands gratitude
for the country he has been given that's
that's the major difference in our
politics people who are grateful for the
principles of the declaration of
independence people who are grateful
for what they have been given if they
didn't hit a triple they were born on
third base
and people who have decided that all the
good things in life are natural to life
and that we can simply dispense with all
the systems that created those things
because those systems are inherently bad
and terrible
okay so it wasn't all glory last night
there were a couple of speakers who are
not
particularly wonderful the one who got
the most attention of course was
kimberly guilfoyle the former fox news
host and and donald trump
juniors are they married yet uh i think
she's his girlfriend
uh kimberly guilfoyle um spoke last
night
and forgot there was no crowd so it got
really uh really awkward here's a little
bit of the awkwardness president trump
is the
leader who will rebuild the promise of
america
and ensure that every citizen can
realize their
american dream ladies and gentlemen
leaders and fighters for freedom and
liberty and the american dream
the best is yet to come
and then resident silence so that works
when there's a crowd there maybe
um but there was no crowd there so uh
that got real awkward real fast that was
that was not
not a i mean she used to be on tv so
that feels like not a really good
tv decision that person who actually was
shockingly good last night was donald
trump jr there are a lot of people who
are concerned that donald trump jr was
going to
just go out there and be over the top
and wild and actually
he was pretty good like his speech was
actually kind of shockingly good
he talked about the fact that the
democrats have been using kovat as an
excuse to actually give away money to
their rich democratic friends this is
true
nancy pelosi has stacked into the relief
packages
state and local tax deductions right
which is a way for
california to charge insane levels of
taxation and then take the money out
from the federal government coffers
essentially here's donald trump jr going
after that
after eight years of obama and biden's
slow growth
trump's policies have been like rocket
fuel to the economy and especially
to the middle class biden has promised
to take that money back out of your
pocket
and keep it in the swamp that makes
sense though
considering joe biden is basically the
loch ness monster of the swamp
for the past half century he's been
lurking around in there
he sticks his head up every now and then
to run for president
then he disappears and doesn't do much
in between okay well he
correct fact check true trump jr also
went after the canceled culture that is
being promoted by the democrats by the
way
the canceled culture is so strong right
now and and the insane level of
sensoriousness is so strong right now
there's a video that's going around on
twitter it's pretty incredible of a
black lives matter activist
literally walking up to people at a
washington dc restaurant and demanding
that they raise
their fist in a salute to black power
and when two people who are just sitting
there are like no
they start berating them publicly that
is where we are as a country and it
ain't good
here was donald trump jr going off on it
last night
joe biden and the radical left are now
coming for our freedom of speech
they want to bully us into submission if
they get their way
it will no longer be the silent majority
it will be
the silenced majority this has to stop
freedom of expression used to be a
liberal value
at least before the radical left took
over now the republican party is the
home of free speech
the place where anyone from any
background can speak their mind
and may the best ideas win okay
and then he also added by the way when
we downline one would be nice if
it didn't go to voicemail because since
the democrats are intent on cutting the
cops
in the middle of major cities burning
that's probably a bad idea
what happened to george floyd is a
disgrace and if you know a police
officer
you know they agree with that too but we
cannot lose sight of the fact that our
police are american heroes
they deserve our deepest appreciation
because no matter what the democrats say
you and i both know
when we dial we don't want it 911
to voicemail so defunding the police
is not an option everything starts with
safety and security
you can't have anything else without it
okay
so these were all of the lead-up
speeches then there were the two
kind of con concluding speeches and they
were both great
and these are both figures who are going
to be very important to the future of
the republican party
one is former ambassador to the un and
my spirit animal nikki haley and the
other was senator tim scott both of them
gave i thought excellent speeches
last night the media have been trying to
pretend that these were sort of outliers
right the media's goal here is to
pretend that the republican party is all
of trump's worst excesses
that it is not in fact comprised of
candidates like nikki haley
and tim scott and so what they attempted
to say well they're out of step with
sort of the trumpian base no they're
they're really really not i mean both of
these figures are very popular inside
the republican party so nikki haley
pointed out correctly that joe biden
has basically taken the strategy of
blaming america first for all problems
in the world this is absolutely true
here is the the former governor of south
carolina former u.n ambassador
under president trump and a person with
a great personal story by the way i mean
both tim scott and nikki haley are
people
who appreciate america because of their
background right nikki haley
is the daughter of two indian immigrants
and um
would never be treated by the way with
the same sort of kid gloves that the
media have treated kamala harris
who's the daughter of jamaican immigrant
and an indian immigrant uh here's here's
nikki haley
talking about joe biden blaming america
first
i'll start with a little story it's
about an american ambassador to the
united nations
that ambassador said and i quote
democrats
always blame america first
the year was 1984. the president
was ronald reagan and ambassador gene
kirkpatrick's words
are just as true today
joe biden and the democrats are still
blaming america first and that is
exactly
right now nikki haley got ripped up and
down by the media last night why
well number one because she was good but
mostly because
she pointed out that america's not a
racist country she had yes there are
races here
some people do racist things i've been
hit by those people but
america is not a racist country now this
is such an important distinction
okay i have been personally targeted by
anti-semites for a lot of my career
in 2016 i was named the number one
target of online anti-semitism
an enormous amount of it springing from
the alt-right but i've been hit by
anti-semitism from members of the left
i've been in with all sorts of
harassment right there are lots of nasty
people
online and in real life there are lots
of nasty people is that america's fault
it is not america's fault
you can actually have experienced bad
things in america and not blame the
entire country that gives you freedom
and that was the point nikki haley made
eloquently last night and the media
decided to completely ignore
in much of the democratic party it's now
fashionable
to say that america is racist
that is a lie america is not
a racist country
this is personal for me i am the proud
daughter of indian immigrants they came
to america and settled
in a small southern town my father wore
a turban
my mother wore a sorry i was a brown
girl
in a black and white world we faced
discrimination
and hardship but my parents never gave
in to grievance and hate
this is a great point that you can
criticize people in america
you can if you spot racist incidents you
can fight them you can fight racist
obstacles that doesn't mean the entire
country is racist it's such an important
point
and the reason the democrats hate nikki
haley is because she has the credibility
to say stuff like this
it's the same reason that they hate
senator tim scott so
tim scott spoke last night he was
excellent
and again the media couldn't deal with
it so they just decided to treat tim
scott as an outlier
scott said the election is about the
promise of america this is exactly right
here is the
black senator from south carolina
republican
while this election is between donald
trump and joe biden
it is not solely about donald trump
and joe biden it's about the promise of
america
it's about you and me our challenges and
heartbreaks
hopes and dreams it's about how we
respond
when tackling critical issues like
police reform when democrats called
our work a token effort and walked out
of the room
during negotiations because they wanted
the issue
more than they wanted a solution exactly
right
here's tim scott making the point that
i've been making for weeks here when it
comes to racism democrats are more
interested
in labeling everyone they don't like
racist and labeling the system racist so
that you will give them power then they
aren't actually solving problems
and tim scott should know since he's the
one who proposed the police reform bill
democrats then filibuster
scott also gave an inspiring message
about the fact that this is an
incredible country he says my family
went from cotton to congress in one
lifetime i know we're supposed to
pretend that racial progress has not
taken place
i know we're supposed to pretend like
isabelle wilkerson that we're still
living in a cast
system in the united states we're
supposed to pretend like abram kennedy
that racism just went underground and
reemerged as all of our soft systems of
institutional power it's a lie
here is tim scott rebutting the lie
my grandfather's 99th birthday
would have been tomorrow growing up
he had to cross the street if a white
person was coming
he suffered the indignity of being
forced
out of school as a third grader to pick
cotton
and he never learned to read or write
yet he lived long enough to see his
grandson
become the first african-american to be
elected to both
the united states house and the united
states senate
in the history of this country our
family
went from cotton to congress
in one lifetime and that's why i believe
the next american century can be better
than the last
okay isn't that a better message than
the message being put forth by people
like kamala harris that america is
systemically racist and that you're
always behind the eight ball or michelle
obama and there's a never-ending list of
black people being victimized in the
united states
right now isn't that more inspiring and
a truer message
so scott says democrats basically want
to fundamentally transform the country
the same country that has allowed for
that sort of progress
again correct senator scott
joe biden's radical democrats are trying
to permanently transform
what it means to be an american
make no mistake joe biden
and kamala harris want a cultural
revolution
a fundamentally different america
if we let them they will turn our
country
into a socialist utopia and history has
taught us that path only leads to pain
and misery especially for hard
working people hoping to rise so the
media's response to this was absolute
abject horror that members of minority
communities would dare speak as
republicans my favorite
version of this was george
stephanopoulos grilling nikki haley on
racism
because george stephanopoulos who is the
whitest person in america the keebler
elf
grilling nikki haley the daughter of two
indian immigrants on racism because
george stephanopoulos knows racism i
mean that's a man who knows racism
obviously here he was suggesting that
nikki haley is truly
making room for racist because she's
supporting president trump
i asked you what president trump has
done to heal that racial divide and you
know you wrote that you were deeply
disturbed
by president trump's comments after
charlottesville since then he's tweeted
out a video of his supporters chanting
white power
praised the confederate flag which you
called divisive in your speech last
night so i'll ask the question again
what specifically has president trump
done to address this systemic races in
the racial divide
well i will tell you first of all
president trump has passed criminal
justice reform which obama and biden
didn't do
so my favorite thing from democrats is
when they question how president trump
has bridged the racial divide while
democrats are actively trying to widen
the racial divide
actively doing it it doesn't make
excuses for all the
bad things trump has said over the
course of his career but right now if
you're looking
at people who are actively attempting to
create racial divides in the country the
democrats members of the media but i
repeat myself
are doing exactly that that's what
you're watching happen
ad nauseum in wisconsin right now you're
watching it happen
day by day in the media right now and
they cannot stand the fact that
republicans
actually there there's some minority
republicans who disagree with that
democratic agenda
alrighty we'll be back here later today
for two additional hours of content
otherwise we'll see you here tomorrow to
recap night two
of the rnc and whatever the the black
lives matter riders and looters decide
to burn tomorrow
or tonight well we'll give you all the
updates this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas our technical director is
austin stevens
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producers are mathis glover
and robert sterling
assistant director pava wydowsky our
associate producer is nick chien
the show is edited by adam syavets audio
mix by mike caromina hair and makeup is
by nika geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
democrats burn down another city
left-wing professors are calling for the
abolition of the english language
and the rnc kicks off check it out in
the michael knowles show
[Music]